محمد يا هلا وسهلا صبحكم الله بالخير
وصباح الخير على المشاهدين قناه العربيه
وعودا حميدا لقناه لصباح العربيه مجددا
فاهلا وسهلا
اليوم نتحدث عن
اليوم
اهلا وسهلا اليوم بنتحدث عن اطلاق برنامج
تعليم المانجم المانجا لطلاب وطالبات
التعليم العام في السعوديه حيث اطلقت
وزارتي الثقافه
التعليم برنامج تعليم المانجم لانتاج
القصص لطلاب وطالبات التعليم في مراحل
المتوسطه والثانويه في المدارس الحكوميه
والاهليه
والاجنبيه ياتي هذا البرنامج ضمن الانشطه
اللا صفيه الافتراضيه المطبقه عبر منصه
مدرستي وهي تقدم حلقات متعدده عادل وراويه
مشاهدينا
يعني تعلم من خلال يتعلم من خلالها الطلاب
والطالبات هذا البرنامج تقدم من خلال هذه
الحلقات يعني
لهدف تنميه قدرات اذا بنتي سمعته راح تروح
على السعوديه مباشره قدمًا بتحب
والله راويه الجميع سعيد
اخذوها اشواقين
الجميع والله سعيد يعني البارحه اتساءل
واسال الطلاب والطالبات ومن يهوى هذا يعني
الهوايه في جميعهم سعيد وخذوني معكم حتى
انا طيب يا محمد الهدف من هذا البرنامج هو
يعني تنميه القدرات
نعم نعم عادل اليوم اليوم بالتاكيد تنميه
هذه القدرات واصبح هناك
انتاج اصبحت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ايضا تنتج وقبله لهذا الفن اللي اصبح
اليوم
بصناعه ضخمه كبيره جدا مو بس عند
اليابانيين
دوختنا اشواق فيها شكرا لك يا محمد شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات